[Music]
happy birthday
how me it is this year marks 100 years
since communism began three PI feet and
building by building about to the debate
the first revolution was in Russia he
never contacted a the government
improvement now no longer would
capitalists exploit workers now the
people would prosper together under live
[Music]
but some people resisted so Lenin
ordered them killed you need to hang
without fail he said so the public sees
the death of the rich the bloodsuckers
Stalin continued the killing millions of
people starve because it turned out that
when farmers can't control their
property they don't produce much food
yet today many leftist anti-fur
activists carry Communist flags some say
well Russia just didn't do communism
right but when has anyone done it right
the Chinese said they would make
communism work instead a mob of
teenagers called the Red Guard lined up
sceptics and executed them millions were
murdered yet even after years of murder
many Chinese people still believed look
at these people they are crying not
because they're unhappy they're crying
with joy and excitement just because
they got to see their leader Chairman
Mao I was brainwashed for entire those
of school years Mao was like a god to me
I couldn't listen to him talking to me
from the clouds just like a religion
right but Chinese communism failed even
the people who worshipped it I was so
hungry all the time my uncle told me how
to trap rats but the prison everybody's
just trying to catch rats and rats run
out too
it was horrible it was horrible Lily
Tang was a little girl then she loves
Mao now he died I really do not know
what to believe it's like I start to
realize what's a lie I was 12 but you
look at my picture when he died I was
wearing big arm black bed and crying my
eyes out but about eight years later I
met a u.s. exchange student we made a
dancing
we start dancing that type opened
obviously it come to my room next David
I wish you something
he showed me a pocket Constitution he
read to me first the paragraph
Declaration of Independence it's like my
Pokemon as I have rights
oh man created equal doesn't matter
which country which race which color I
have rights
the he puts something in my head I come
to America my family all were crying
when I left I
I do not know anybody in the US no
friends in Austin Texas
just sponsor Lilly came to America with
nothing but he or she thrived and last
year she ran for US Senate as a
libertarian
she pulled high enough to make the
debates I got a hundred thousand votes
her message was that life is terrible
without freedom after all my sufferings
in China my wakening process this is I
was born to do before she became a
libertarian she became a Republican but
then I 2008 when they bail all the banks
when Bush come out to say capitalism
feel I've abandoned free-market
principles to save the free market
system it just shocked me they use
taxpayers money to bail the banks and I
feel the Republican supposed to fall to
before limited the government they
expanded Medicare today well no child
left behind and civilians all this stuff
I got so mad I reaches liebecker in 2008
so I become like activist when Colorado
debated gun control she posted this
picture on Facebook with the caption I
once was a slave I will never be one
again I was holding my ar-15 to send a
strong message
she told Colorado's legislature the
history of China might have been
different had the Chinese had a right to
bear arms now she speaks at colleges she
says many young people haven't learned
the lessons of communism total
brainwashed don't know the truth trust
Authority and trust the government so I
hope more students listened up
Lily Tang Williams big powerful Carmen
it's very scary it will keep growing
like cancer will never stop if you
empower government not individuals we're
gonna lose this free country that's not
what I came here for I got a three
children now like I'm gonna fight here
I'm gonna turn the weight you suck don't
blend crap to my country
you